aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de ce
smartphone ce smartphone c'est le Honor
Magic 5 Pro alors je vous l'ai déjà
présenté quand j'étais à Barcelone et il
est temps aujourd'hui de vous donner mon
retour sur son smartphone vous expliquer
toutes les techno alors je vous le dis
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec Honor au
Norma dimension Dreux est-ce que tu
voudrais pas nous faire un tour complet
de ce smartphone nous expliquer les
techno nous montrent les photos alors
les photos ça sera dans un temps de dans
une autre vidéo parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses à dire au niveau de la photo
également ici au niveau de la vidéo sur
ce smartphone donc là on va se
concentrer sur les différentes techno
qui à l'intérieur au niveau de l'écran
au niveau de l'audio au niveau de la
performance il y a 4 puces il y a pas
mal de choses à venir raconter également
au niveau de l'autonomie il y a
énormément de choses à savoir ce qui est
génial et ce qui est super intéressant
ici avec ce smartphone et bien c'est que
c'est le smartphone le plus haut de
gamme jamais construit par Honor alors
au nord refait rapidement un petit tour
de l'histoire ils sont indépendants
depuis quelques petites années
aujourd'hui de Huawei ils sont en train
d'écrire leur propre histoire qui est
différente de ce qu'il y avait avant
avant c'était la marque John de Huawei
aujourd'hui c'est une marque complète
avec des produits à 360 degrés il y a
des smartphones d'entrée de gamme il y a
du milieu de gamme il y a du très haut
de gamme ici comme avec le Magic 5 Pro
et une déclinaison également de la gamme
Magic 5 je vous invite d'ailleurs sur le
site de Honor pour tout découvrir et je
vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description il y a également des
smartphones qui se plient donc il y a
beaucoup d'innovations beaucoup de
techno on va essayer de comprendre
comment ça se passe qu'est-ce qu'on peut
venir à voir quels sont les intérêts
quels sont les avantages et surtout
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est intéressant
2023 de venir acheter un smartphone de
Honor et notamment dans le trio de gamme
avec ce Honor m'a dit que ça me prend
allez on y va
[Musique]
première chose avec ce Magic 5 Pro c'est
un smartphone qui est assez grand assez
gros il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients les avantages c'est que
vous aurez une très grande nage assez
pratique pour tout ce qui va être
contenu multimédia pour venir s'amuser
pour du gaming pour tout ce que vous
voulez c'est grand vous avez largement
la place l'inconvénient c'est que
lorsque vous le prenez à la main comme
ça vous voyez et bien ça reste un
smartphone quand même qui est
relativement grand j'arrive pas à faire
le tour avec ma main alors j'ai pas une
énorme main mais je fais pas le tour
complet mais au moins rassurez-vous je
tiens quand même relativement bien dans
la main donc pas de souci ici on est sur
un smartphone qui fait ces 219 g c'est
pas le plus léger du marché mais il sait
rien de déconnant par rapport au
smartphone et plus haut de gamme qu'on
retrouve sur l'ensemble du marché ici il
y a rien qui me surprend alors il existe
dans deux couleurs la couleur que je
vais avoir ici c'est la couleur black
c'est le black c'est le noir il est noir
il est un petit peu brillant c'est le
black et vous avez également le Mido
green que je vous avais présenté lorsque
je l'avais eu en main à Barcelone ou MWC
la différence que vous allez avoir
vraiment entre les deux coloris c'est
que le dos qu'on va avoir ici sur le
noir sera un dos qui sera davantage
réfléchissant on se voit à travers un
petit miroir ça reste très élégant mais
on se voit réellement à travers tandis
que le Mido green laser en fait c'est
une couleur qui va être un peu plus
matte qui va pas avoir particulièrement
de reflet lorsque vous l'avez en face de
vous alors si vous me demandez mon avis
personnel parce que je vous entends en
train de me le demander il y a moi j'ai
préféré les couleurs verte et ici le
gros travail café au nord et bien on est
sur l'oeil de la muse c'est-à-dire que
vous avez ce gros bloc photo au centre
ici qui est sympa qui donne une vraie
symétrie c'est vraiment extrêmement
symétrique comme smartphone et petit
anecdote ce qui est très marrant lorsque
je suis venu shooter en studio et bien
je mettais ma tête moi j'ai un boîtier
en fait qui va venir reconnaître les
yeux et bien je ne mettais comme ça je
mettais le smartphone derrière et il
croyait effectivement que c'est un œil
reconnaissait le smartphone comme étant
en extrait de petit anecdote donc voilà
je trouve que c'est un smartphone
élégant avec un bloc couteau qui est
assez pro imminent au centre
personnellement je trouve ça sympa ça
marche bien je le préfère en vert mais
bien réussir en tout cas au niveau du
design première particularité technique
de ce smartphone qu'on ne retrouve pas
beaucoup sur des Android et bien c'est
de la reconnaissance 3D au niveau de
votre visage alors si vous regardez ça
vous aura pas échappé que vous avez un
grand module photo sur l'avant qui est
logé sur la gauche de votre écran vous
avez une caméra de selfie ça c'est bien
et voilà des photos un peu plus tard
mais vous avez également un autre
capteur qui vous permettra d'avoir de la
reconnaissance en trois dimensions et à
la différence de beaucoup de smartphones
sur Android on fait du fayshundlock
c'est de la reconnaissance en deux
dimensions pour venir déverrouiller et
bien là vous avez beaucoup plus sécurisé
ce qui vous permettra de venir
déverrouiller votre smartphone grâce au
relief de votre visage en trois
dimensions et ça servira également pour
du paiement sécurisé donc ça c'est quand
même vachement cool alors il y a
différentes façons de venir le
déverrouiller vous avez les schémas vous
avez les codes vous avez également le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
situé au milieu alors je vous le dis il
est situé un peu bas je trouve ici
j'aurais préféré qu'il soit un poil plus
haut mais bon rien de bien gravé ici
puisque je viens de déverrouiller avec
mon visage je le prends je lève il me
reconnais et des verrous ce serait
pratique donc ça c'est bien alors un des
gros points forts de ce smartphone et
bien c'est son écran vous avez un très
grand écran je garde mes notes là vous
les avez vu j'ai pas tout appris par
cœur je ne connais pas les fiches
techniques par cœur mais par contre j'ai
tout vous expliquer parce que je me suis
bien amusé avec on a ici un très grand
écran de
6,81 pouces c'est un des plus grands
écrans du marché je vous cache pas que
c'est une dalle qui est assez énorme
c'est fait vraiment lien par rapport à
ce que je vous expliquais tout à l'heure
par rapport à la taille de ce smartphone
qui est assez grand fatalement on a un
grand écran un grand ça va te perdre
est-ce qu'il va te faire également c'est
que c'est un smartphone qui est incurvé
dans les quatre côtés donc vers le haut
vers le bas vers le droite vers la
gauche alors qu'est-ce que ça raconte ça
et bien ça fait qu'à côté très immersif
au niveau de ce smartphone alors tout le
monde n'aimera pas les smartphones qui
vont être incurvés il y en a qui aiment
pas la cancer incurvé à droite et à
gauche alors là on vient d'incure vite
tous les côtés ça peut venir perdre
quelques personnes pour moi l'intérêt
réellement d'avoir cette incurvé et bien
c'est vraiment d'apporter en immersion
lorsque vous allez venir regarder du
contenu vous amusez des films des séries
ça fonctionne parfaitement bien l'écran
ici est très bien maîtrisé c'est une
dalle qui est très très très bien
calibré et en plus vous avez un mode par
défaut qui vient de vous mettre c'est
les couleurs vives c'est extrêmement
pétant alors peut-être un peu trop
saturé on peut venir le moduler dans les
paramètres si vous préférez un mode un
peu plus naturel vous pouvez l'avoir
alors il y a plein de techno ici
puisqu'on est sur cet écran on se parle
d'un écran avec une dalle OLED ça
viendra jouer au niveau de l'autonomie
mais ça on en parlera un petit peu plus
tard puisque un pixel noir est un pixel
éteint donc ça c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal fichu mais surtout c'est une
dalle ltpo qui vous permet d'avoir un
taux de rafraîchissement d'une variable
mais qui descend vraiment très très bas
lorsque vous êtes en train de lire un
article ça va également venir jouer au
niveau de l'autonomie de votre et là où
ils sont venus s'améliorer par rapport
aux Magic 4 pro l'année dernière et bien
c'est la luminosité on a un pic de
luminosité à 1800 nets là vous voyez
typiquement il y a du soleil le soleil
arrive en tout cas parce que tout à
l'heure c'était pas le cas et bien là
vous avez du soleil autant vous dire que
ça vous permettra d'aller relativement
loin en extérieur je le prends je peux
venir regarder du contenu je suis pas
embêté donc ça c'est quand même
vachement cool alors c'est vrai que
lorsque je viens de filmer directement
sans rend pas nécessairement compte
parce qu'on a l'impression que je vois
pas extrêmement clair avec alors pour
autant je vois très très clair je vais
essayer de vous le montrer comme ça mais
ça va pas être extrêmement évident au
travers de la caméra je vois super bien
aucun problème de visibilité là je le
souhaite dans le dos donc pour venir
regarder du contenu pour venir faire des
emails pour venir chatter faire ce que
vous voulez directement alors que vous
avez le soleil même dans le dos comme ça
absolument aucun problème donc ça c'est
vraiment un très gros point fort très
rapidement vous avez une très grande
résolution on se parle de 2848 par 1312
pixels et le truc qui est intéressant
mais c'est pas tout nouveau en fait vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement qui va
jusqu'à 120 on connaît Dolce smartphone
avec des taux de rafraîchissement qui
ont plus haut mais je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on attend
d'un smartphone très haut de gamme
d'avoir un minima un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 100 m et
ici le Magic 5 Pro est totalement dans
les clous il sera très très bien
l'affaire on se si un écran avec un
milliard de couleurs IMAX and hdr10 plus
donc vous avez toutes les certifications
ici c'est donc un très bel écran qui va
bien en terme de multimédia vous avez
vraiment ce qu'il faut je me suis fait
du gaming j'ai regardé des films je
regardais des séries et je puis vous
assurer qu'en termes de confort de
visionnage vous avez vraiment un truc
qui marche merveilleusement bien alors
il y a un autre truc sur lequel au nord
est venu travailler qui est super
intéressant je vous explique c'est tout
ce qui va être protection de vos yeux
lorsque vous allez venir regarder du
contenu je pense notamment lorsqu'il y a
moins de luminosité avec un petit effet
Flickr mais ça vous vous en rendez pas
compte mais par contre vos yeux il
mordent et arrivent un moment ça
fonctionne pas bien alors il y a plein
de marques qui travaillent effectivement
à améliorer les smartphones en
conditions de faible luminosité pour
éviter la fatigue oculaire mais là au
nord je dirais tu allais un peu plus
loin et c'est là où c'est intéressant de
voir les techno qui viennent implémenter
au niveau de leur smartphone alors si
vous avez regardé sur leur site web vous
aurez vu qu'il vous propose une
gradation en PWM à 2160 Hertz alors ça
va pas forcément venir vous parler cette
techno on va pas rentrer vraiment dans
le détail de la techno ce qu'il faut
venir comprendre c'est la fréquence que
vous allez avoir en condition de faible
luminosité et bien comme vous avez une
fréquence qui est beaucoup plus élevée
et bien ça va venir éviter que vous ayez
de la fatigue oculaire alors c'est pas
perceptible une fois de plus à vos yeux
lorsque vous les regardez comme ça mais
si vous regardez un smartphone en
condition de faible luminosité au
travers de l'écran d'un deuxième
smartphone vous avez commencé à venir
comprendre de quoi je vous parle il y a
un autre mode qui a mis en place assez
purement logiciel ça au nord dans son
smartphone c'est un respect du cycle
circadien alors pour faire très simple
c'est le cycle de votre sommeil
c'est-à-dire que lorsque vous avez moins
de lumière le soir qu'est-ce qui va se
passer et bien avec moins de lumière
votre corps va commencer à sécréter de
la mélatonine qui est l'hormone du
sommeil et si vous vous mettez des
écrans en pleine face pendant des heures
au bout d'un moment vous allez retarder
la sécrétion de mélatonine et vous
n'allez pas venir vous endormir donc ça
va retarder l'endormissement des nuits
le plus court beaucoup plus de fatigue
bref c'est pas terrible et donc
justement au nord a mis en place un mode
spécial un mode nuit vous pouvez venir
programmer ou activer afin de venir
moduler la température de couleur de
votre écran qui va passer d'une couleur
un peu plus blanche et une couleur un
peu plus jaune pour éviter justement
qu'on vienne perturber le cirque
circadien et que la production de
mélatonine arrive plus tard donc comme
ça vous êtes tranquille autre point et
qui n'est pas un détail qui est
intéressant votre smartphone va venir
s'adapter à la lumière environnante
et c'est justement ce que viennent faire
et si toute cette technologie on s'en
fout d'avoir les techno pour les techno
mais les techno elles sont au service de
vos usages améliorer la consultation de
votre contenu très facilement 120 images
par seconde lorsque vous allez venir
scroller ça va être très fluide ça sera
hyper agréable à venir visionner donc
voyez plein de techno ici qui a mis au
nord au service de votre confort alors
l'expérience multimédia on en parle
beaucoup au travers de l'écran mais il y
a également toute la partie audio qui
est extrêmement importante ici vous avez
des haut-parleurs stéréo je pense que ça
vous aura pas échappé on est dans un
smartphone très haut de gamme on nous
met donc des haut-parleurs stéréo on a
pas exactement la même qualité audio à
droite qu'à gauche le haut-parleur de
gauche sera plus fort plus puissant et
celui de droite sera haut parleur de
renfort qui apportera en terme de
spatialisation l'expérience multimédia
est bonne mais c'est pas le meilleur
smartphone pour avoir une expérience de
stéréoscopie soyons clairs le son est
très beau et très peu de smartphone vont
venir avoir la meilleure expérience et
dans le très haut de gamme tous les
compétiteurs ils font quasiment la même
chose donc pour moi là-dedans il est
dans la course il y a absolument aucun
problème à savoir qu'ici vous avez du
Bluetooth 5.2 avec les principaux codecs
SBC AAC vous avez de la PTX de la PTX HD
donc bon voilà il sait pas de mauvaise
surprise pas le taf attention on est
dans du très haut de gamme il y a pas de
prise d'Irak rien ne s'en prenant ici
donc on a une expérience multimédia
globale avec d'un côté la vidéo de
l'autre côté l'audio qui est très bonne
très bien maîtrisé bravo Nord alors je
vous parle d'écran je vous parle d'audio
maintenant je veux qu'on parle un peu
plus de ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur de ce
smartphone pour essayer de comprendre
comment est-ce qu'il est fabriqué alors
on va pas regarder au niveau des puces
qui nous intéresse non ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de comprendre la
performance qu'on va avoir à l'intérieur
et l'autonomie grâce à la batterie alors
ça on le verra juste après mais on va
commencer par la performance alors on
s'en doutera sur un smartphone très haut
de gamme honoré vue nouvelle ce qui
aujourd'hui le mieux sur le marché sur
Android c'est le stand dragon 8 GN2
alors je voulais présenter je vous ai
emmené avec moi à la conférence de
guelcome on a regardé ça ensemble il y a
quelques mois on est aujourd'hui sur une
puce extrêmement puissante vous en avez
en fait plus sous le capot que ce que
vous allez réellement faire avec et
surtout c'est une puce qui est
complètement optimisée à l'intelligence
artificielle cette puce elle va être
intéressante pour plein de choses déjà
pour tout ce qui va être expérience de
gaming vous avez beaucoup de
performances et performances brutes
aujourd'hui tous les jeux qui existent
vont pouvoir tourner sans aucun problème
grâce à cette puce sur un smartphone
Android donc ça c'est vachement bien
elle sera aussi très bonne du point de
vue photo elle va qui aurait
significativement la qualité des photos
donc ça va venir apporter en plus à tout
le travail qui a fait au nord au niveau
de la partie photo mais ça on en parle
dans une prochaine vidéo donc venez vous
abonner si c'est pas déjà le fait
cliquez sur le bouton rouge si les
rouges et que vous n'êtes pas abonné
puis pensez à venir activer la cloche
pour être notifié dès qu'une prochaine
vidéo arrivera donc ça vous voyez c'est
vachement bien en plus de ça ils nous
ont mis quatre puces donc vous avez la
puce de quoi comme la première vous avez
en plus une puce d'amélioration RF radio
fréquence donc il va venir améliorer
pour tout ce qui va être communication
vous avez également une puce de sécurité
dédiée qui va venir améliorer bien
évidemment la sécurité notamment liée à
vos biométries empreinte digitales
reconnaissance de votre visage et vous
avez une autre plus dont je vous ai déjà
parlé un peu tout à l'heure c'est la
puce d'affichage dédié qui va venir
ajouter de la fluidité donc vous
rajoutez des images à votre contenu
passer de 30 FPS à 60 fps ça va apporter
plus de stabilité à l'image donc vous
voyez il y a toutes ces puces là qui
vont venir apporter on a donc la puce
principale qui est le cœur de votre
smartphone qui est le saint dragon 8 GN2
et puis vous avez les autres plus que va
venir nous ajouter ici au nord pour
améliorer significativement l'expérience
et rendre ce smartphone encore plus
premium alors avoir un beau smartphone
c'est bien maintenant on va au
smartphone qui soit endurant dans le
temps donc on va venir regarder tout qui
se passe sous le capot au niveau de la
batterie alors l'autonomie globale
d'ailleurs c'est pas que la batterie
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est à
dire que c'est une addition de plein de
facteurs qui vont faire que vous allez
avoir une bonne autonomie déjà le
premier truc a fait au nord ici c'est
qu'ils sont venus augmenter la capacité
de la batterie on avait une batterie de
400600 milliampères heure avec le Magic
4 pro on est passé à 5100 milliampères
heure donc on a gagné 500 millions par
heure ce qui globalement est quand même
plutôt pas mal la batterie va être plus
grosse on pourra stocker davantage
d'énergie par rapport à ce qu'on avait
sur le modèle de l'année dernière alors
il y a un autre carré d'huile c'est le
bloc de charge vous avez un bloc de
charge qui inclut attention ça c'est
quand même vachement cool de 66 watts
contre 100 watts l'année dernière donc
déjà globalement ça vient changer un
petit peu l'histoire alors 66 watts 100
watts ça va pas changer grand chose en
temps de charge ça reste de la recharge
rapide donc ça quand même c'est bien
maintenant je cours par cette question
d'autonomie l'autonomie c'est pas
uniquement la capacité de la batterie de
votre smartphone on le voit souvent sur
les smartphones d'entrée milieu de gamme
il vous met des grosses batteries parce
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de techno
derrière et qu'il faut des grosses
batteries pour permettre d'aller un peu
plus loin quand on arrive sur un
smartphone très haut de gamme c'est pas
très grave si les batteries sont un peu
moins gros parce qu'il y a plein de
techno qui vont permettre d'emmener
votre smartphone un peu plus loin déjà
ici le premier point c'est la puce le
saint dragon 8 les deux est très bons au
niveau de l'énergie emmènera à votre
smartphone un peu plus loin au niveau de
l'autonomie ça c'est le premier point
vous avez déjà une plus grosse batterie
500 millions d'empereurs de plus donc on
arrive à 5100 millions d'erreurs c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal fichu en plus
de ça vous êtes sur un écran OLED je
vous l'ai dit les pixels noirs sont des
pixels éteint vous avez toutes les
technologies de luminosité adaptative
d'un point de vue logiciel qui
permettront d'emmener votre smartphone
aussi un peu plus loin et puis les
technologies de RAM et de Rome tout ce
qui va déjà en terme de RAM qui
permettra d'optimiser tout ça avec de la
lpdr5x qui va permettre effectivement
d'être joué également au niveau de
l'autonomie et puis la Rome vol stockage
c'est de l'UFS 4.0 qui permettra
également de jouer au niveau de
l'autonomie sans oublier l'expérience
logiciel ça permettra également d'aller
un peu plus loin donc tout ça vous
permet d'avoir un smartphone qui va
pouvoir tenir dans le temps sans aucun
problème et si vous commencez à manquer
un petit peu d'autonomie et bien vous le
branchez vous le charger vous êtes parti
vous êtes tranquille donc en termes
d'autonomie si vous avez un smartphone
qui est très cool et en plus de ça il
est compatible charge sans fil 50 watts
là par contre il faut venir acheter
votre bloc de charge en plus que vous
n'avez pas ici alors très rapidement la
partie photo même si c'est pas trop le
sujet aujourd'hui j'ai quand même vous
montrer quelques images mais juste avant
de vous montrer ces images je veux qu'on
restitue un petit peu ce qu'on a d'un
point de vue matériel on a un triptyque
50 mégapixels un grand angle 50
mégapixels qui vous permettra de
regrouper 4 pixels en 1 pour les photos
en faible luminosité ça c'est le premier
point avec une stabilisation optique on
va également avoir un ultra grand-angle
qui fait macro également en 50
mégapixels sans oublier un zoom
périscopique 50 mégapixels avec un zoom
optique enfin 3,5 et on peut aller
jusqu'à 1 x 100 on va regarder le
résultat et on fera vraiment le détail
dans la prochaine vidéo donc une fois de
plus penser à venir vous abonner sans
oublier une mise au point laser ici en
d'étoffe c'est cool et une caméra de
selfie de 12 mégapixels voilà d'un point
de vue purement matériel au niveau de la
photo je vous montre rapidement quelques
photos pour vous ayez une idée
globalement de ce qui va donner ce
smartphone en termes de photos et bien
évidemment on en reparle dans une
prochaine vidéo vraiment accès photo
vidéo de ce smartphone parce que c'est
un des gros points forts de ce
smartphone alors regardez là je vous
emmène on est à côté du Cap Ferret c'est
un petit peu saturé au niveau de l'herbe
mais ça reste très flatteur très joli
très bien maîtrisé on continue alors
désolé si vous aimez pas les huîtres
globalement mais c'est pour venir voir
un peu la macro viens voir ce qu'on peut
avoir et là je trouve que c'est vraiment
pas mal fait juste même très très bien
avec ce capteur ultra grand temps qui
restitue vraiment très très bien la
macro un peu les ambiances également je
trouve que l'ambiance est très jolie ici
de ce que propose ce Honor Magic 5 Pro
on continue avec une photo regardez là
paf les pieds à marée basse c'est très
joli là une fois de plus grand angle
ultra grand temps alors il y a une
différence de colorimétrie entre le
grand angle ultra grand temps il est un
petit peu plus violet ultra grand-angle
et après on peut se rapprocher bon après
vous allez voir que le zoom façon c'est
pas ouf mais bon voilà ça me paraît pas
non plus déconnant ici une fois de plus
l'ambiance est là c'est beau c'est joli
c'est maîtrisé sur l'ultra grand temps
et on vient zoomer une fois de plus ici
la caméra de selfie aussi est pas mal du
tout regardez là au niveau des teintes
de peau il y a pas de lissage c'est bien
fait ça me paraît vraiment pas mal le
mode portrait aussi est bien détour bien
on peut venir régler son flou mais ça on
en parlant une fois plus dans la
prochaine vidéo mais je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment bien fichu une fois de
plus l'ambiance globale que j'aime
beaucoup ici des vagues c'est beau on
peut venir shooter plein de choses là
sur l'ultra grand-angle avec ce chemin
qui monte et lorsque vous avez du soleil
vous avez des couleurs qui sont là qui
sont belles qui sont juste grand angle
ultra grand angle regardez ça on vient
se rapprocher un peu là l'eau est un peu
plus voyez là elle est un peu plus tire
un peu sur le verre là on est plus eux
et là c'est un bleu un peu foncé donc il
y a quelques petites différences au
niveau de la colorimétrie mais
globalement c'est quand même super joli
là c'est pareil je peux vous montrer un
peu les différentes couleurs je serais
vraiment très très bien alors il y a un
côté par moment un peu sur saturé mais
bon ça me dérange pas ici là j'aime bien
une fois de plus les ambiances sont très
jolies sur ultra grand-angle et on vient
voir et là sur de la nourriture donc
vous voyez les photos elles sont très
alléchantes alors on regardera ça un peu
plus tard lorsqu'on en parlera mais ici
pour l'instant ce qu'on voit c'est
vraiment bien tout en sachant ici que
dxmark lui donne le meilleur score en
photo pour un smartphone vendu en France
score de 152 alors ça c'est toujours une
fois de plus à prendre avec des
pincettes c'est un TOP scores des xomack
je vous ai déjà parlé d'eux je l'ai déjà
montré leur labo voir comment est-ce
qu'il faisait on en reparle bien
évidemment lors de mon test photos je
donnerais tout mon retour comme ça vous
aurez également ce que j'en pense moi à
titre perso mais les photos déjà tel
qu'on peut commencer à les voir on voit
que derrière il y a du répondant
franchement alors je conviens un peu sur
les techno on a d'autres technos qui
sont intéressantes on va commencer par
une certification ça certification
IP68 qui certifie que votre smartphone
va être résistant aux éclaboussures à
l'eau il y a la poussière alors pas pour
aller se baigner dans une piscine mais
si vous voyez il pleut et bien il y aura
pas de problème donc bon ça c'est ce
qu'on attend un minima dans smartphone
dans les haut de gamme et ici on l'a sur
le Honor Magic 5 Pro on a en plus de ça
ici du wifi 6 pas de wifi 6e un peu
dommage tout en sachant qu'il y a quand
même pas mal de smartphone qui commence
à arriver avec du wifi 7 donc au nord
nous a permis de wifi satisfait on se
contente de wifi 6 qui fera très bien
l'affaire soyons clair mais c'est vrai
que pour un smartphone extrêmement haut
de gamme on aurait pu s'attendre à avoir
du wifi 6e voir peut-être du wi-fi 7 en
tout cas minimal Wi-Fi bon vous voyez
ici c'est pas le cas on a bien
évidemment du NFC pour le paiement des
matérialisé ne technologies que vous
avez présenté l'année dernière au nord
c'est une technologie à base
d'intelligence artificielle c'est lia
privacy call en fait c'est quoi ça fait
que lorsque vous passez un appel
téléphonique et bien il y a tout un
travail qui est fait à base
d'intelligence artificielle pour éviter
les fuites sonores pour éviter que la
personne qui est à côté de vous puisse
entendre ce que vous êtes en train de
dire donc il y a tout un travail
algorithmique à base qui est fait
justement pour que vos conversations
privées restent justement privées autre
technologie ce sont les gestes à
distance comme vous avez une caméra en
trois dimensions qui va pouvoir venir
reconnaître et bien les volumes vous
allez pouvoir venir faire pas mal de
choses avec différents gestes tourner
les pages d'un bouquin faire une capture
d'écran tout ça en ayant votre
smartphone qui soit posé en face de vous
donc sans le toucher c'est aussi
sur le site de Honor et une fois de plus
je vous mets le lien juste en bas dans
la description votre smartphone qui
coûte 1199 euros ça le tombe à 1099
euros et c'est 100 euros sont toujours
mieux dans votre poche que dans les
poches Léonore soyons clairs alors au
nord je vous en ai déjà parlé c'est
aussi un écosystème d'ailleurs je vous
invite à aller jeter un coup d'oeil à la
vidéo écosystème pour voir tout ce que
vous pouvez trouver si vous voulez aller
dans l'écosystème au nord il y a de la
montre il y a de l'écouteur il y a de
l'ordinateur de la tablette il y a tout
un ensemble qui vient communiquer
ensemble donc ça c'est vachement
intéressant puisque aujourd'hui ce qu'on
attend de nos objets c'est qu'il soit
plus intelligent facile à utiliser qui
viennent totalement communiquer les uns
et les autres si vous êtes créateur il y
a un sujet qui va vous intéresser c'est
le retour des Honor Magic Moments alors
c'était lancé en 2021 les Honor Magic
Mommens permettent de partir à la
rencontre de différents créateurs alors
en 2022 il y avait plus de 300000
participations autant dire que si vous
n'avez pas peur 2022 vous pouvez tenter
votre chance cette année en 2023 je vous
mets le lien dans la description le
thème de cette année c'est quand la
technologie rencontre la nature vous
voyez typiquement ici on y est vous êtes
donc invité à réfléchir entre le lien
qui existe entre la nature la
technologie il y a différents qui
peuvent être abordés là-dessus à l'issue
de la compétition il y aura 59 prix qui
seront distribué par le jury
international et aller savoir vous
souhaitez être un des lauréats pour
venir participer je vous mets également
un lien dans la description donc dites
moi vous ce que vous en pensez de ce
smartphone qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
toutes ces technologies est-ce que vous
êtes intéressé est-ce que ça peut vous
intéresser de venir avoir un smartphone
de Honor est-ce que ce Magic 5 Pro vous
fait l’œil une fois de plus je vous mets
le lien juste en bas dans la description
marquez moi tout ça et on se retrouve
très bientôt pour continuer à parler de
ce smartphone mais de vue photo point de
vue vidéo on va regarder tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec et ça croyez-moi c'est
aussi un sujet extrêmement intéressant
parce qu'on se parle ici d'un smartphone
juste très haut de gamme avec plein de
techno donc on va regarder ce que le
saint dragon 8 gène 2 peut venir faire
ici avec ce smartphone tout le travail
qu'on peut faire en vidéo bref ça va
être top on se retrouve donc très
bientôt pour en parler d'ici là prenez
soin de vous je vous embrasse et moi je
vais pas nager parce que il fait pas
encore assez chaud mais en tout cas je
vous embrasse pour l'instant une fois à
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]